est-ce que Manuel Macron doit recevoir
l'interse syndical c'est ce qui est
demandé je vois bien comment ce ce débat
là au fond comme souvent je vais essayer
de prendre des objets vous voyez
politique très symboliques et puis que
toute la vie du pays tourne pendant 48
heures autour de ces questions-là la
réalité c'est qu'il y a un gouvernement
qui est profondément à l'écoute dans le
dialogue social c'est son rôle c'est son
rôle le rôle du président de la
République c'est de donner le cap pour
le pays c'est de défendre les grands
enjeux du pays la cohésion aussi
internationale évidemment il le fait il
est assuré
de l'agriculture il y a quelques jours
il était longuement interrogé il a pu
s'exprimer donc j'ai trouvé que ces
débat là où pendant qu'un jour on dit
est-ce que le président parle trop et
puis les 15 jours suivants est-ce qu'il
ne parle pas assez et tout ça c'est
quelque chose qui est dans le landerneau
politique moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
la vie des Français c'est en
l'occurrence singulièrement la vie des
agents de la fonction public nous sommes
un gouvernement je crois qui est
vraiment dans le dialogue social vous
savez moi je passe beaucoup de temps
encore maintenant avec les organisations
syndicales à travailler la suite les
grands enjeux le dialogue n'est pas
rompu c'est ce que vous voulez dire ce
sont des enjeux de pouvoir d'achat sont
des enjeux de santé au travail sont
d'égalité salariale tout ça c'est des
enjeux mais je le dis parce que parfois
quand on regarde les plateaux de
télévision on a l'impression que tout ça
n'existe pas ça n'est pas vrai c'est des
enjeux qui comptent évidemment que le
débat sur les retraites est un débat
très bien
[Musique]